Donald Trump posted a video a video
response we're going to play this video
for you right now we have this from
truth social he says I'm an innocent man
the bite Administration is totally
corrupt this election this is election
interference and and a continuation of
the greatest witch and of all time make
America great again let's uh let's play
the video
we're I got it I got it just got it yeah
look at him get some lighting on your
face Don and yet wait
very sadly We're a nation of decline
and yet they go after a popular
president a president that got more
votes than any sitting president in the
history of our country by far
and did much better the second time in
the election than
the first and they go after him on a
boxes hoax just like the Russia Russia
Russia hoax and all of the others this
has been going on for seven years they
can't stop because it's election
interference at the highest level
there's never been anything like what's
happened I'm an innocent man I'm an
innocent person they had the Mueller
hoax the Mueller report and that came
out no collusion after two and a half
years that was set up by Hillary Clinton
and Democrats but this is what they do
this is what they do so well if they
would devote their energies to honesty
and integrity would be a lot better for
our country they could do a lot better
they could do a lot of great things but
when you look at what's happened to our
country in the last three years we were
energy independent we had a strong
military that wasn't woke we were doing
so well we were respected all over the
world got the biggest tax cuts in
history biggest regulation Cuts in
history and what do you do you have a
president where an election was taken
got more votes than any sitting
president in history by far never
anything even close
and they come after me because now we're
leading in the polls Again by a lot
against Biden and against the
Republicans by a lot but we're leading
against Biden by a lot a tremendous
amount
and we went up to a level that they
figured the way they're going to stop us
is by using what's called Warfare
now that's what it is this is Warfare
for the law and we can't let it happen
we can't let it happen our country is
going to hell and they come after Donald
Trump weaponizing the justice department
weaponizing the FBI we can't let this
continue to go on because it's ripping
our country to shreds we have such big
problems and this shouldn't be one of
them it's a hoax the whole thing is a
hoax just like Russia Russia Russia just
like the fake dossier was a hoax you saw
the Durham report you saw the Mueller
report it was all a big hoax you had two
impeachments and they lost and we won
and we had tremendous support
but that was a hoax and a scam and now
they're doing it again it's just a
continuation seven years even after I'm
out but it's called election
interference they're trying to destroy a
reputation so they can win an election
that's just as bad as doing any of the
other things that have been done over
the last number of years and especially
during the 2020 election
so I just want to tell you I'm an
innocent man I did nothing wrong and we
will fight this out just like we've been
fighting for seven years it would be
wonderful if we could devote our
full-time to making America great again
and that's exactly what we did but now
again our country is in Decline we're a
failing nation and this is what they do
I'm an innocent man we will prove that
again seven years of proving it and here
we go again very unfair but that's the
way it is I just want to thank everybody
we are doing something very special for
our country we're putting America first
I always put America first
and that's why we were in a position
unfortunately that position is no longer
valid because they've done such a poor
job
but we're in a position where we're
going to make America great again I'm
innocent and we will prove that very
very soundly and hopefully very quickly
thank you very much I think you said I'm
innocent like yeah that would make if
someone cut that up and made an
auto-tune of a song called I'm an
innocent man that would be so badass
that actually would be and he is
innocent until proven guilty he's
innocent yeah I think he's just genuine
generally innocent because I don't
believe anything they're living against
him so yeah Mr Weiss you're a crisis guy
right so I'm gonna say a lot what's
going on here a lot of times I have this
scenario with uh clients and their
lawyer and the lawyers always say don't
speak don't speak and I say don't listen
to lawyers they're just gonna hold you
back it's very important that President
Trump spoke right now 50 60 million
people want to hear from he showed
strength he showed confidence
he showed that he's still in High
Spirits because most probably most of
his attorneys saying don't say anything
don't go out there keep it quiet you
might slip you might say something to
Trump you never know but it's very
important I think tonight that he spoke
out and I would have given the advice
speak out
what if like he posted a video he was
crying
like behind a bed sheet or something
like Chris Crocker
what kind of human goes through this
it's unbelievable seven years of torture
and he's still trying to still trying to
run but Trump's the kind of guy I
imagine when the camera goes off he
starts like punching the wall he doesn't
think so yeah I don't think he's the
kind of person who's like I can't
believe there's doing this to be like
where would they stop he's the kind of
guy who's like oh I will destroy them
build me something great so I can
destroy it'll be another one I bet he's
like raising his voice I bet he's going
to his lawyers back why isn't anything
getting done how is this still happening
I want lawyers yeah he looked like he
was freaking out I was there the night
he got indicted from the uh the city
district attorney and he was he flew
right in and did a big speech at
Mar-A-Lago we went upstairs afterwards
and he's DJing the whole night two in
the morning what like on the record
he takes his iPad he takes the iPad when
he's there and he's he becomes the DJ
are you serious he's like just picking
music that night yeah he's just he goes
he goes from Sinatra to Elton John I'd
rather imagine it with like the one
headphones you ruined that by giving
more details
he just got indicted
in the morning and having a great time I
said unbelievable I think he's a TJ he's
like getting in diet reviews the coolest
president we've ever had that's not even
a question
like he's probably got a lot of
streakers trouble with the law yeah we
did a cartoon about that a little while
ago and now it's happening again it's
like I don't know why I bother to keep
making these every week when the news is
just reruns now yeah one of my favorite
lines from him that he says constantly
and he said it a couple times in this
speech is that he received the most
votes of any sitting president
specifically because Biden wasn't a
sitting president obviously at the time
but he keeps saying that the most votes
of any sitting president he's not
sitting right now quite frankly he's
laying he's laying down you know he's
not awake it's just like a funny cop-out
when he's not the president right now
and he just keeps saying it's true
though and it's true from a sitting
president yeah but I've still got more
votes but his point is no other uh uh
what is it no other sitting president
received more votes and lost sure we're
a growing population with more voter
participation every four years so it's
like uh
I think we've never had more money in
our economy than we do right now
covid played a major role in why this
didn't look the same way as it did
because they basically just locked
everybody in boxes and then tortured him
for it and then mail-in ballots and that
played a huge role which DeSantis said
he wants to start doing aggressively and
we'll see if Trump follow
I just think like
the the fabric of this nation has been
ripped to shreds oh yeah and now it's
just
you know before it was things were
heating up now at the highest level like
the fact that the Biden doj is just like
well I can't beat him so let's lock him
in jail but like okay ripping the fabric
apart if the fabric is being used to
suffocate your friend and you rip the
fabric to shreds and save your friend's
life that maybe that fabric needed to be
ripped apart anyway so like are we
better off or worse off since Trump
became president not Hillary but that
that doesn't quite make sense right the
the fabric of this country is what stops
the people from from fighting each other
in the streets the fabric of this
country is the basic rule set of look
we're not going to indict our political
rival we're going to let people vote
about these things we're not going to
make up BS charges right now in the
public sphere we know for a fact Joe
Biden is corrupt Politico wrote about
this years ago Biden Inc we know that
his family's fortunes have tracked his
career in in federal government we now
have another story basically confirming
he was getting bribes to fire the
prosecutor Joe Biden publicly admitted
he went to the president of Ukraine and
said fire the prosecutor or I will
illegally withhold loan guarantees he
just come out
and they don't do anything about it if
the people of this country know for a
fact that the government has been
weaponized against one half of the
population like we are dangerously close
to whatever you want to call it oh boy
the metaphor you were looking for Ian
was like a fracture doesn't heal fully
but you need to break the arm completely
for it to heal fully not that I agree
with what if with that's what breaks if
your bone is fractured then it doesn't
heal completely but if it breaks
completely then it does properly heal
that's a bad metaphor for what I think
should happen in the nation but I think
that's a cleaner metaphor for what
you're looking for a clean break you
know Biden is so fascinating to me he's
this uh he's like for as much as people
say this about Trump Biden is this
character study in the hubris of man
because he's so late in his life and
he's putting such little emphasis on his
soul in so much emphasis on money and
being corrupted his family
he's well firstly Kennedy if we're
including fake Catholics Kennedy was a
fake Catholic President before Joe Biden
uh no I think Kennedy was actually
practicing but we know behind the scenes
I was doing Marilyn Monroe yeah we know
there were some some stuff going on
there that would throw him outside of
like you know you know he was not
practicing my point is yeah yeah no I
know you can't trust those guys that's
my whole argument that's the whole point
Joe Biden I mean
Catholics and politics are Irish flag
behind you tonight I know what are you
talking about when was there ever one
you know the Catholics don't need to get
into politics because the Vatican has so
much power I don't know about that dude
I don't step down into the politics
realm they already
know but if you think religious
institutions may have more influence and
power over Earth than sit in governments
I mean but well that's the thing you
know I'm Catholic I love my church but
you know there are obviously people in
the Catholic church I've been very
critical of and people in the hierarchy
and I think it was Chesterton who said
this but one of the reasons I believe
it's the true church is because I don't
know how an organization can spend so
much time being corrupt and still exist
it's been like 2 000 years with these
horrible reasons we're still here who's
gonna have faith in the justice system
anymore after this oh no but after this
after January it's such a joke they got
to do something good I mean for me to
regain faith in them they'd have to do
something we have videos of Hunter Biden
that you can't show even an 18 year old
agreed but you know what you know what
I'll I'll say is that at this point
we've become so tribal that credibility
is irrelevant thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL pod cast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time